where the North has its honor and the
south it's chivalry the Iron Islands has
its strengths we call ourselves the
Ironborn and we are warriors feared
throughout the Seven Kingdoms also we
used to be unlike their mainland cousins
the first men of the Iron Islands never
bowed to the old gods theirs was the
drowned God who made the Ironborn to
reeve and sack
and write their names in salt steel and
song that his enemy the storm God could
not wash away we raised our kings from
our own ranks and used beaten foes as
thralls to work our minds in farm our
land or assault wives if a woman was
pretty enough such was the old way and
while we followed it we held sway
wherever the waves were heard when Aegon
came demanding fealty King harren the
black ruled as far east as the Trident
other kings like the Starks could kneel
but Heron was Ironborn and the Ironborn
must be beaten in Harrenhal he had the
mightiest castle in Westeros and the
army to defend it but Aegon did not
intend a siege he mounted his dragon and
roasted harren and all his sons in their
Tower and the old way with them
because of herons defiance Aegon pushed
the Ironborn back to our islands and
gave the river lands to the Tully's but
he did allow the Ironborn to choose who
would lead them house Greyjoy had always
been one of the greatest houses of the
Iron Islands we trace our descent from
the Age of Heroes and the legendary grey
King who took a mermaid to wife and made
war upon the storm guard for a thousand
years blessed by the drowned God the
Great King fought since Lunada the great
sea dragon and took her fire for his own
this history made our ancestor Vic on
Greyjoy the natural choice to leave the
Ironborn after Aegon's conquest for 300
years house Greyjoy ruled the Ironborn
we styled ourselves lord of the Iron
Islands king of Sultan Rock son of the
Seawind Lord Reaper of Pike in truth we
were thralls how people still chanted
what his dead may never die but the old
way had died until the Targaryen
followed their dragons into the grave
and our Lord father Balin Greyjoy rose
against the new King Robert Baratheon
he seized our ancient crown and sent our
iron fleet against the Lannisters at
Lannisport burning all their ships
before any could weigh anchor though
Robert and Eddard Stark would later
defeat him they understood us no better
than egg on the Greyjoy Siddal is the
Kraken what a grasp wants it will never
surrender
what is dead may never die but rises
again harder and stronger